- Good afternoon everyone.
I am Kristina Talbert-Slagle,
Assistant Professor at the
Yale School of Medicine
and Director of the
Faculty Support Initiative
at the Yale Institute for Global Health.
I am also the Principal Investigator
for Applying Research
for a Healthy Liberia,
a five-year collaborative project
with the University of Liberia
College of Health Sciences
and Vanderbilt University,
funded by the U.S. Agency for
International Development.
I am delighted to welcome you
to this Global Health
Conversation series event,
Ebola Ten Years On, Reflections
and Lessons Learned.
in addition to the Yale Institute
for Global Health, or YIGH,
today's event is co-sponsored
by the Walker Fund
and the Council on African Studies
at the MacMillan Center at Yale.
This December marks
the 10 year anniversary
of the emergence of Ebola
in the West African country of Guinea,
an event that caused a tragic epidemic
and more than 10,000 deaths in Guinea
and its neighboring countries,
Liberia and Sierra Leone.
Since the 2013 to '15 Ebola epidemic,
the world has experienced
numerous global health threats,
such as further Ebola
outbreaks, Marburg, measles,
and COVID-19, among others.
During this webinar, three
senior health leaders
who responded to the
Ebola epidemic in Liberia,
Guinea, and Sierra Leone
will share their reflections
on the weaknesses in
healthcare, public health,
and health financing
that exacerbated the Ebola
crisis in their countries,
as well as lessons learned that can be,
or have already been,
applied to respond better
to emerging infectious disease threats,
build more resilient health systems,
and improve health outcomes globally.
It is our pleasure to have
three distinguished guests
joining us today,
all of whom are esteemed
leaders in global public health.
To formally introduce our panelists,
I will now turn to my
colleague, Dr. Sabine Franklin.
- Hello everyone.
My name is Dr. Sabine Franklin,
and I'm a Mellon Postdoctoral Fellow
in the Africana Studies
Department at Wellesley College.
It is my pleasure to introduce
our distinguished panel
and to moderate today's event.
Dr. Bernice Dahn was the
Minister of Health of Liberia
from 2015 to 2018,
and previously served as
the Chief Medical Officer
of Liberia from 2006 to 2015,
where she oversaw post-war health systems
strengthening efforts.
She is currently the Vice President
for Health Sciences at
the University of Liberia,
leading the College of Sciences,
which houses the only schools of medicine
and pharmacy in the country,
as well as the New School of Public Health
and Nursing Midwifery Program.
Dr. Dahn has authored
more than 40 publications,
spearheaded an investment plan
for building a resilient health system
in Liberia post Ebola,
and is internationally recognized expert
in health system strengthening
and pandemic recovery.
Dr. Sylla Thiam is a
public health specialist
with more than 20 years experience
in health management and
leadership across Africa.
He is currently an independent consultant
and a part-time research associate
at the University of Thies in Senegal.
He has been with Amref Health Africa,
the largest healthcare
nonprofit on the continent
from 2011 until 2018,
when he was the regional
director of Amref in West Africa.
Prior to that, he worked
with the Ministry of Health
in Senegal in various positions
at district and national levels
leading various campaigns,
notably the reduction of the malaria cases
via systemic changes to
the ministry's surveillance
and delivery of services.
Paramount Chief, David Mandu
Farley Kelli-Coomber IV
is an experienced engineer
who spent two decades in the United States
before returning to Sierra Leone in 2008
to work in the mining sector.
He was elected to head the Mandu Chiefdom
in the Kailahun district
on December 2nd, 2013.
A few weeks later, the first
case of the Ebola virus disease
in a child occurred in
Gueckedou prefecture in Guinea,
which borders the Kailahun District,
and it ultimately caused the child's death
and triggered the 2013 to 2016 pandemic.
Thus, one of his first
governance challenge
was to implement emergency bylaws.
He convinced other paramount chiefs
in the Kailahun district to
implement the same bylaws,
to discourage movement, close contact,
and encourage help seeking behaviors.
These were later scaled up
and implemented as part of Sierra Leone's
National Emergency
Declaration in August 2014.
So, welcome to all of our panelists.
It is great to have
you here with us today.
So we are moving now to the first round,
and I ask each panelist this question.
It has been 10 years and tens
of thousands of articles,
photos, and reports on
the deadliest outbreak
of the Ebola virus disease.
What parts of the narrative
or the story is missing?
And can you tell us that
story in two minutes?
I will start with Dr. Dahn.
- Thank you and hello to everyone
who is on to listen.
So, it's 10 years after the outbreak,
and during the outbreak
there was this momentum
to build resilient
healthcare delivery systems,
to ensure that the impact of outbreaks
will not be felt like the way it was felt
during the Ebola outbreak for countries.
And countries should be better prepared
for new emergencies.
Which part of the story
that is not being told,
there was momentum to support countries,
strengthening countries,
along building the resilient
healthcare delivery systems.
Countries supported
countries that were weak
to help them build
the resilient healthcare delivery systems.
Promises were made.
Some of those promises were not fulfilled.
Not every promise that was
made was a new promise,
and moving onwards,
whether countries still
align to the efforts
of building the resilience
that we all felt
should have been built
within the outbreak of
Ebola and moving on.
So for me, I will summarize that to that
and wait for the next question, thank you.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
So we'll move on to Dr. Thiam.
Could you please tell us
what parts of the story
or the narrative is
missing in two minutes?
- Okay.
(Sylla Thiam, speaking in French)
- Paramount Chief
Farley, could you tell us
what part of the narratives
or the story is missing?
And could you please tell
us that in two minutes?
- Two issues.
There are many, but two principle issues.
One is how important the
governance structure,
governance issues are to properly
address emergent diseases,
and specifically a problem like Ebola.
I can give examples of that later on.
That's the first issue.
The second issue is that,
in terms of local populations,
Ebola was a very severe crisis,
but keeping it in perspective,
there are still normal
diseases that are endemic here
that probably that kill
so many more people
long after the international
efforts have been
very well appreciated.
International efforts
were made to combat Ebola.
I'm talking specifically
about malaria and typhoid,
which continues, unfortunately,
to take a very high mortality toll
on our regular populations.
And so while we are very
happy about the attention
that was brought to our
healthcare issues by Ebola,
by the Ebola epidemic,
there's an ongoing endemic
of regular diseases
that need to be addressed
and that the population will want
people like me to keep talking about.
- All right, thank you,
Paramount Chief Farley.
And so we'll bring it back to Dr. Dahn.
What was the most significant
challenge you faced
during the Ebola crisis in your country?
And how did you respond?
- Initially, coordinating to our partners
to align to and respond to
the emergency was challenging.
We had an emergency and
everyone was willing to help.
So we had a lot of influx of partners,
both donors and implementing partners,
coming in to help.
We were having coordination meetings,
but from the initial stages,
those coordination meetings
were not very efficient,
and so partners were like parachuting,
going, and doing things on their own
until we were able to regroup,
design a system that brought in
the Incident Management System,
established Emergency Operation Centers,
mapped out the partners,
and divided them geographically
to support specific
things within the counties
and help to build a county health capacity
before we were able to get it straight.
- All right, thank you, Dr. Dahn.
And Dr. Thiam,
what was the most significant
challenge you faced
during the Ebola crisis
when you were in Guinea?
And how did you respond?
(Sylla Thiam speaking in French)
- Thank you, Dr. Thiam.
And Paramount Chief Farley,
what would you say was the
most significant challenge
that you faced on Ebola in Sierra Leone?
- Okay, there are several issues,
but I think they all
center around the fact that
Ebola was the first really
major modern health crisis
that the country had experienced.
And so the first thing was
the very negative reaction
of our local communities.
We're a little bit fortunate
that it started in the rural areas,
and by the time it had
gotten to the urban areas,
the situation was still bad,
but at least the government
had had some experience
with what was happening.
But the major issue there was a stigma
associated with the disease.
When a community suddenly starts seeing
there are several members
of their community
going to hospital and dying consistently,
and when they saw ambulances
come into community,
they will usually, the
youth will gather up
and throw stones at the ambulances
and maybe not even accept
those health initiatives.
Also because of sick stigma
associated with the disease
and high fatality that was involved
in the disease, because of a
very poor healthcare system,
when you had Ebola it was
basically a sentence of death.
And so people used to hide the fact
that they had Ebola at all,
and that obviously helped
in its transmission.
There was also the issue of
people wanting,
our culture dictates that we
have a very caring community.
Usually people usually visit sick people,
and especially when somebody dies,
a large number of people in communities
usually attend to that person.
And obviously in the case of Ebola,
people who got in contact with somebody
who even died from Ebola
or got sick from Ebola
will easily get the disease.
So it became almost a
hopeless situation where
if they say you have Ebola
or if somebody got sick,
he will hide the fact that he was sick.
Even if he was just he or she
was just sick with malaria or typhoid
or some really perfectly curable disease,
they will deny that
they have that disease,
because once they were told,
the authorities knew that they had Ebola,
they'll be taken to an Ebola center
where they'll invariably never return.
It got a little bit
better as time went on,
when we had better facilities.
- Sorry, Paramount Chief
Farley, I have to interrupt.
You got 10 seconds left.
- Okay, it got a little bit better,
but that was the main issue
that we had to deal with.
Then of course we had to deal with
the poor governance
structure that we have.
But I'll address that later on.
- Okay, thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
So we're moving on to the next round
where each panelist will
have one minute to respond.
So if a panelist is responding
and another panelist likes
the points that they made,
they can raise two fingers,
such as I'm demonstrating,
and they can add on to that
person's point for 20 seconds.
Or if you can raise a full hand to object,
if you wanna give a dissenting view.
You'll have 30 seconds to give that view,
and then the original panelists will have
30 seconds to respond to that view.
And yes, I am timing it on my timer.
So we will be begin with Dr. Dahn.
You also have the unique experience
of working inside a Ministry of Health.
And what do you feel were the challenges
of integrating those NGO resources
in a government response and
how can that be improved?
- Is the question related to
the Ebola or just the overall?
- It's related to Ebola for now.
- Okay, okay, so yes, thank you.
Normally partners, both donor partners
and implementing partners,
will stress accountability,
efficiency, and accountability.
Working with the government,
you'll realize that accountability
is a one-way street.
Okay, so I was saying
normally within global health
we all stress accountability
and efficiency,
effectiveness and efficiency.
When you work in the government,
you realize that accountability
is a one-way street.
Donor partners tend to hold
governments accountable
for resources that are provided for them
from their countries,
but the country, the recipient,
does not have the same opportunity
to ask for accountability
in the other direction.
So you'll realize that, for example,
a donor gives an NGO maybe $10 million.
- Oh, Dr. Dahn, could
you wrap up the example
in just 10 seconds, please?
- Okay, a donor gives
an NGO $10 million to support services.
You ask for detailed services.
A detailed breakdown of that
budget is difficult to get.
And so it becomes difficult
to align that resource
to resources that you already have
to be able to complement one another.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
And for Paramount Chief Farley,
can you please tell us
about the interactions
between emergency responders
and the local communities, you know,
such as the burial teams,
healthcare workers,
that you had mentioned earlier?
- It started out really bad.
As I said, the first time
I actually noticed that
there was a problem
in the country, or at least in our region.
We had just come back
from (voice muffling).
- [Shannon] Farley, we're
having a trouble hearing you.
If you could speak a
little louder, please.
We're having a little trouble hearing you.
Thank you.
- All right, and I said the first time
I noticed that we had a
problem in the country
was when we were traveling from a meeting
of paramount chiefs in
Kailahun district at night,
and I saw a huge crowd on the roadside
attacking an ambulance.
And I had to come down and
I asked what was going on.
I found out that they said
the ambulance people had said
they had brought in a corpse
who died from a new disease
and that there were under instructions
not to let the people handle that corpse.
And so there was a huge
hue and cry about that.
But that was the start.
But then unfortunately,
or maybe, I don't know, providentially,
in that same chiefdom,
not very long after that,
the wife of the paramount chief died.
And so there was a much better thrust
of wanting to handle this issue together
so that by the end of the epidemic
there was a very, very good relationship
between the community, the
medical care providers,
and the traditional leaders like us.
So it started out very badly,
but over a period of time we ended up
with a fairly good relationship,
and it's a good lesson that we'll learn
for future interventions.
- All right, thank you.
Dr. Dahn, can we go back for you
to finish your thought, please?
In terms of, so what were the...
Oh, I'm sorry, to the original question,
what were the challenges of
integrating those NGO resources
into the government response
and how these can be improved?
So, you left off at accountability.
- Yes, so I was saying it is difficult to,
especially for implementing partners
to share detailed budgets,
and so aligning those budgets
to what you already have,
resources that you have,
to ensure that they complement
one another is difficult.
Take for example, quite
recently there was an RFA.
We decided to join with
an NGO partner to apply.
The RFA, one of the terms
is to strengthen local health systems.
And so in that RFA 50% of the budget
should go to local institutions.
The international partner was the one
priming, we agreed to that.
They broke down the budget
and gave us about 5.4
out of $24 million for over five years.
We did a detailed budget for our portion
of the $24 million, which is the 5.4,
but we just couldn't get
them to give us the details.
And we were partners on the
table designing a project.
And that is, even, it is not the only one,
but it's been happening.
I've noticed a difference
with training institutions
and also the health sector.
Most U.S. universities, for example,
will tell you our overhead is 25%, 35%.
So you know that, and when
you are designing the project,
you take that into consideration,
but all the U.S. NGOs
will not tell you what their overhead is.
Is not negotiated with their government.
It's outside of it,
so you really don't know
what their overhead is.
And then at the end of the day,
you realize that what
actually goes to the project
is by far less than what it is.
And that has implications for government,
because when you sign
a $50 million project,
for example, in Liberia,
Liberians want to see $50
million worth of projects,
in terms of implementation.
And so when they don't see that,
they feel that the money has
been (voice cutting out).
Government is abusing the
money and things like that.
But many times those monies
don't even come to the country.
A good portion of it don't
even come to the country,
and you really don't see how much
to really say this is the amount
that actually went with
program and services
and this went into overhead for others.
And that I've seen the difference also
with some of the U.S.
training institutions
that they'll be transparent,
and we'll all work the budget together.
Ask (voice cutting out) NGO partners that
you really don't know how it goes.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
I see Paramount Chief
Farley has two fingers up,
so please add on.
You have 20 seconds.
- Yes, I'll just add that
there's an accountability issue also
on the part of our national governments.
I govern a local
(indistinct) local government
that used to exist even
before the colonial era,
and our people implicitly trust
their paramount chiefs significantly,
much more so than central government.
But even when we get donations
to our central governments,
very little of it triggers
into our local communities,
into chiefdoms,
like we have, for instance.
And so it's a double whammy.
Dr. Dahn has a problem with
accountability from NGOs.
We have a problem,
but NGOs still give a little
bit to the central government.
But even that little bit,
the central government they
give the central government,
does not get to the communities
which actually get to implement
things that actually address
the diseases, the problems
we have in our communities.
So I just wanted to address that.
- Thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
And to follow up finally
with the Dr. Thiam.
So you also have the unique experience
of working inside a Ministry of Health
and then working for a
major health NGO, Amref.
So what do you feel are the challenges
of integrating NGO resources
in this type of government
coordinated response?
How can that be improved?
(Sylla Thiam speaking in French)
- Thank you, Dr. Thiam.
And thinking now, going
back to the very beginning
of the Ebola epidemic
and the misconceptions around it,
such as stigma, local culture or customs,
or the involvement of local
communities in some regions,
as a result, distrust developed
between those communities
and those seeking to control the epidemic.
So, after working in
these different regions
and your position as
regional director of Amref,
what have you learned
and how can we prevent
mistrust between communities
and public health responders?
(Sylla Thiam speaking French)
- Thank you, Dr. Thiam.
And Paramount Chief Farley,
thinking about the
international responses,
for example, MSF or Western governments
that are often put in a spotlight
when dealing with a global
health crisis such as Ebola,
how has your work with
other paramount chiefs
demonstrates that local communities
are capable of meeting these challenges?
So how can international organizations
or other governments better
support local communities
to address future emergencies?
- Deal with paramount chiefs directly.
Most of our communities
have traditional governance structures
that the communities trust
a whole lot more than
the national government.
Most of our national governments
are essentially inheritance of a mantle
of the colonial authorities.
And unfortunately in a
lot of African countries,
especially in the rural areas,
or in the vast majority of the country,
the people in governance in a major,
at the national level
basically take an attitude
of a colonialist towards the rural areas.
And so, like in Sierra Leone,
things are very highly centralized.
Most of our traditional structures
have been weakened significantly.
And since our productive capacity
has been reduced also significantly,
to a large extent, we
depend to a large extent
on funds coming in from outside.
Now, a lot of these funds go
directly to the government,
but a lot of it also goes to NGOs.
None of it goes to paramount chief
and local leaders directly.
And yet we are the
people that people trust
more than anybody else to deliver
the care that they need.
So my suggestion,
one way we could think
about it is obviously
get our NGOs very accountable,
but also give them instructions
and find a way to monitor whether
they have had direct relationships
with traditional leaders
of those communities.
And there are all sorts of ways
that we could structure that.
But on a large, like on a broad basis,
I think that probably
is the best way to go.
International countries or organizations
and NGOs when they come, yes,
you need some permission from
the government to operate,
but make sure that most of your resources
are directed towards direct interactions
with your traditional
leaders whom the communities
respond to a lot better
and who are a lot more
accountable to the communities.
- Thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
And Dr. Dahn, we wanna
wrap up this section.
Can you please tell us
about the lessons learned
from Liberia's experience with Ebola
and how that could have been
informed for this current
or recent outbreak with COVID?
- Thank you.
The systems we put in place
for the Ebola outbreak help
us with the COVID outbreak.
It was during the Ebola time
that we established
the emergency, the IMS,
Emergency Management System,
the Incident Management System,
and then established these
EOCs in the 15 counties,
Emergency Operation Centers.
We also put in place a
full surveillance system
from community-based events
reporting to real disease surveillance,
active surveillance system
within the communities
all the way to the central level
that is reported within 24, 48 hours.
So, those systems, the IMS,
is normally activated
when there is an outbreak.
And then after the outbreak
(voice cutting out).
The EOCs continue to
function within the counties,
because we will always have some outbreaks
that we can manage normally.
Measle outbreak, for
example, yellow fever,
those things continue.
So the EOC continue to
function at the county level.
So with the outbreak of the COVID,
the IMS was reactivated quickly.
All the EOCs, they are functional,
and so we were able to intervene quickly.
Now we also had a few
challenges with that also.
The central level,
which is the IMS system,
we established during the...
After the Ebola, we established
the National Public Health Institutes,
and the institute is responsible
for disease surveillance
and emergency response.
The definition of that emergency response,
because we know that at some point
the routine health services
had to come in place,
especially for case management
within the emergency system.
So there was this struggle
between the central ministry
and the National Public Health Institute
as to who provides the leadership
for the COVID response.
But fortunately for us at
the decentralized level,
the EOCs were functional,
so they were able to intervene quickly.
And then WHO actually
supported those of us
who were in country and had the experience
of managing the emergency to work
at the decentralized level, some of us,
especially where we had the outbreaks
to be able to curtail the disease.
So the system actually helped us,
and then the impact was not as much
as we saw in other countries.
- Okay, thank you, Dr. Dahn.
So, we wanna move to this last round
before we open it up for Q&A
to give the panelists a chance
to respond to the same question.
So each panelist again will
have 60 seconds to respond.
You can raise two fingers to
agree and add on for 20 seconds
or a full hand to dissent and
then add on for 30 seconds.
And then the original panel member
will have 30 seconds to respond.
So, how can universal
access to primary care,
healthcare, in low income countries
improve global health security?
What do donors in Western-based
agencies need to hear?
We'll start with Dr. Thiam.
Dr. Thiam, you're on mute.
- Oh, okay, not me, right?
- No, Dr. Thiam.
- Okay.
(Sylla Thiam speaking French)
- Thank you, Dr. Thiam.
Paramount Chief Farley.
- Thank you.
First of all, we have to realize that
we live in a much smaller
world now than in the past.
Some diseases aren't quite
as infectious as others,
but they are nevertheless
endemic to the local communities.
But if a community is used to
having very poor healthcare
to even take care of malaria and typhoid
and things like that,
which a lot of people still die of,
not because they don't
know what the diseases is.
But it gets to a point
where they have to choose
between buying food to
eat or buy medicine.
And invariably they'll buy food
or keep buying food until
the disease gets so chronic
that it becomes incurable.
Now, if you have a
community that is inured
to something like that,
when you actually have something
that can be transmitted,
that becomes a threat to Western nations,
like Ebola, people don't
take it very seriously
because they already die every day.
And so they have a very low expectation
of healthcare delivery,
and therefore, they
are not very responsive
to diseases that the West
will take a lot more.
I'll give you an example.
Like, in the case of COVID,
I'll tell you that I don't
know by what miracle COVID
wasn't quite as infectious around here
as it was in the West,
but if it were, it'll have killed
a whole lot more people than Ebola.
But it's the same phenomenon that people
have been used to having
very low expectation
of healthcare delivery system.
And so when infectious diseases come
that could affect the West
because of the travel,
the ease of travel around the world,
that becomes the threat.
So we all have an interest in improving
that primary healthcare
within our communities.
And my final point is whatever you do,
start at the local governance level.
A lot of it at the national level,
never trickles down there,
but I think I'll talk about
it more down the line.
- Okay, thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
Dr. Dahn.
- Okay, thank you.
I will start by saying weak systems
will continue to remain weak
if the systems are not invested in.
The first place is the government.
Often we all look up to
the national government
to invest in building systems.
Now when you look at
the government's budget,
if you take Liberia, for
example, that is a resource,
the low income country
and resources are challenging,
you will realize that about
70 to 80% of the budget
allocated to the health sector
actually goes towards payment
of salaries to personnel.
Now, the salaries also have challenges.
They are salaries that
cannot meet the needs
of the people who are doing the work.
So that's the first thing.
Then you are left with 28 to 30%
of the amount to build all the systems
that need to be in place,
especially at the decentralized level
where the actual services
are being delivered.
That tells you that to
that it will be difficult.
Now, many times we have partners
who are willing to invest in helping,
but they also tend to look at
before they invest and gave
the government the funding
to implement, they will
complain about the weak system,
that they prefer to give the money
to NGOs to implement.
And so the government
system is never built.
Now, NGOs will implement,
and when the funding is
finished, withdrawal.
When they withdraw the work is left back
for the government to take on
and the system is not there to take it on.
So it's a virtual cycle.
Now, within it, the NGO community, too,
there are international communities
and international NGOs
and there are local NGOs.
Normally the international
NGOs are stronger
than the local NGOs.
So, most of the time the funding
also goes to the international NGOs.
And then when they have the funding,
they recruit from within the system,
often the government
system, to do the work.
So, and then they pay better.
So then the government system
is being depleted further.
So the system is never really built
for the government to be able
to take charge of the system.
Now, government, too,
has its own problems.
We have had an opportunity
to move from one government
to another government,
and you realize that some partners
have helped to build some systems.
If you take the financial
management system, for example,
for Liberia, the health, the
Union Ministry of Health,
during the previous administration,
we had donor partners that help us
to put in systems for
financial management,
procurement, and the internal
audit, and the rest of it.
Those systems function to a good extent.
When you change government
and another government comes in,
then the other government,
instead of looking at the system,
the new government looking at the system
that existed and built on it,
they start to do something
else new altogether.
And so what was started
before never get to continue.
And then the system continued to be weak.
So it is both ways,
and that need to be looked into carefully.
The governments themselves,
maybe they don't,
I don't know whether they understand
building a regular system.
It is more political driven
than actual technical work.
And so we continue to
have this vicious cycle
of growing small and taking
like three steps in front
and 10 steps backwards,
once you change government.
And so there's a need to
also really look at that.
The government systems
need to be built properly.
Government and partners work together
to build the system so that
it will be sustainable.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
And I see two fingers.
First from Paramount Chief
Farley and then Dr. Thiam.
Chief Farley, yes.
- Just a quick point to buttress
what Dr. Dahn is saying,
and a solution to the problem that of
changing the whole
system at national level,
whenever you have a change of government,
'cause most of these political
leaders at national level
we don't have a merit system
that exists like in the U.S.
When you have a change of governments,
all of the leaderships,
and even a lot of the civil service,
gets changed, because
they're looking for rewards
for their political supporters.
But, but the good side is
in our traditional leadership
system, like in Sierra Leone,
as much as people criticize it,
our people respect chieftaincy.
I'm never going to have
to stand an election
for the rest of my life,
because our people will trust
that their paramount chief
is going to look after their interests
for the rest of their life.
So, on the other hand,
I'm a lot more accountable to my people,
and I'm just giving myself as an example,
but generally our
traditional governance system
is a lot more stable,
otherwise, our country
will have gone to pots.
So, it's not all hopeless.
Even though there's a lot of
churning at the national level,
there's a lot of stability
also at the local level.
So it'll be good to try to leverage that.
- Thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
Dr. Thiam.
(Sylla Thiam speaking French)
All right, thank you, Dr. Thiam.
And our last question for this round
before we move on to Q&A.
Would it be fair to say that the lack
of universal primary healthcare
is, in itself, a public health emergency?
Dr. Dahn?
- Yes.
The emergency systems are normally built
on the routine healthcare systems.
And most of our people
seek healthcare at the primary level.
The primary level normally is weak,
because one of the panelists earlier said
our governance and the systems
are highly centralized.
So you will realize that
most of the improvement
that is done is done at the
central (voice cutting out).
If you take hospitals for example,
you'll realize that our tertiary hospital,
if you come to Liberia,
we have like two tertiary hospitals.
The biggest one is in Monrovia.
And what that brings to mind is the focus
and the budget that is given
to that is by far higher
than what goes to
primary healthcare level.
And what that brings to mind is
politicians will think about
themselves when they are ill
where they want to go.
And so they tend to invest in that more
at the expense of the primary healthcare,
where the majority of the people
who voted out for them do seek healthcare.
Of course, so when the
primary healthcare level
is not strong enough,
when there's an epidemic,
epidemic can actually (voice cutting out)
and overwhelm the whole country.
So the system need to
be considered as a whole
and not heavily weighed
towards the elites,
which is what is happening
in most of our countries.
Thank you.
- All right, thank you, Dr. Dahn.
It is 1:02, and I want to
get to the Q&A section,
'cause we have so much
engagement from the audience.
So Paramount Chief Farley and Dr. Thiam,
could you please keep your response brief?
- Oh yeah.
- Paramount Chief Farley.
- Primary health, we don't have
much of a primary
healthcare to start with,
because the components
that go into delivering
primary healthcare.
We have one of those
components that we have nurses,
and, you know, auxiliary health workers
and even community health officials.
Most people know how to
diagnose these diseases,
but that's not the real problem.
When you go there,
they are going to inevitably ask for money
that our people don't
have to buy medicines.
And some of them actually
ask for consultations.
And so most people just
don't get primary healthcare,
even though on paper you have
all of these community health
offices, health centers built,
but if you don't have money,
which most of our rural people don't have,
then they don't go there.
And so you have these
auxiliary units coming in,
and it's very dysfunctional.
So we don't have much
of a primary healthcare,
and yes, that is endemic,
that is an epidemic,
because, as I said-
Thank you.
- Yeah, so that's a point I want to make.
- Thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
And Dr. Thiam?
(Sylla Thiam speaking French)
Thank you, Dr. Thiam.
So now I'm looking through the chat
and seeing the questions
that were sent to me from the audience.
I see this first one here
is directed to Dr. Dahn.
"From your experience
"as the former Minister
of Health in Liberia,
"how can international
funding be structured
"to not only address
immediate health crises,
"but also contribute to the establishment
"of enduring healthcare systems?
"Are there successful models or examples
"where INGOs have played a pivotal role
"building long-term
healthcare infrastructure
"in collaboration with local entities?"
- Okay, thank you, yes.
As a country, the first thing
is to provide the directions
for the country and for
those who want to help you.
So countries normally will
develop strategic plans
and policies to provide
directions for the country.
Take for instance, the
health sector policy strategy
on where you want to
take the health sector
over a period of time,
maybe five to 10 years.
Now, implementing the policy
and the strategy is another thing,
because many times people
develop policy strategies
and it's a document and it is
sitting and accumulating dust.
So, working with,
especially the decentralized level
where the implementation is actually done,
normally we do an operational
plan, which is annual.
And in doing that operational plan
is to sit with
all your implementing
partners within the county
and plan to align their resources
to the plan to be able to implement.
Now with my experience,
the first thing is if they plan
the national plans and
policies are done together,
it provides the opportunity
for donor partners
to also be able to align their
resources to your priority.
So that's the first thing.
Now those resources,
when it comes to the implementation level,
those resources also
need to align properly
to the operational plans
that you have in country,
and jointly you can monitor together.
So in Liberia, what we did was to
organize the Health Sector
Coordination Committee, the HSCC,
which is where the health sector
policy decisions are made.
It is normally chaired by
the Minister of Health,
co-chaired by the (voice cutting out).
All the donor partners are present there,
and they tend to give
inputs into the strategy
and the policy,
assign some of their technicians
during the development process.
And so when they are
planning their support,
they plan along those lines
for us and that works.
Now, there are other examples.
I did mention earlier weak
systems will continue to be weak.
We've had situations where
donor partners work with us
to build financial management systems.
For example, currently I'm
at the University of Liberia
at the College of Health Sciences.
Before I got there in 2019,
the College of Health Sciences
had never managed $500 budget.
Everything was highly centralized.
But this is an institution where
faculty members need to
write research grants.
They need to do research,
they need to publish for
their own professional group.
The systems were not there.
We were supported by,
with donor funding by
another U.S. institutions
to build the Office of Sponsored Research,
to build the Office of
Financial Management.
We have a monitoring and evaluation system
in place at the college,
and we have a Human Resource Office,
we have a Communication Office.
Those systems were not there.
And so when people want to support you,
they don't see those systems there.
It becomes risky to put in their money.
Since we started in 2019 to present,
we've managed over $10 million,
or we are managing over
$10 million at the moment,
is because the systems are there.
Of course, with the system currently,
we are not independent yet.
We are still working with the partners
and growing the system
until we can take on fully.
But most of the work is
done within our system,
and they have high level
supervision for it.
And I think that is a very good model,
because at the end of the day
when the international
partner is not there,
that system continues
within the university.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Dr. Dahn.
"Do you think that NGOs cause
mismanagement of resources
"as a whole or individuals with them?
"How can we ensure that resources
"go directly to the community leaders
"to aid local support and governance?"
Dr. Thiam, could you answer this one?
- Okay, I think (speaking in French).
- Thank you, Dr. Thiam.
And I see a question here
for Paramount Chief Farley.
"How can donor agencies and
international organizations
"deal directly with local leaders
"in managing situations like these?
"Do government policies allow for this?"
- Not directly.
If it doesn't,
there's a huge dysfunction
in a lot of our post-colonial countries
where things are very centralized
in the seat of government.
One work around that you can develop,
I'd already mentioned this before,
but I'll say it again.
Yes, it's a good thing to,
if you have credible NGOs,
I mean really credible NGOs,
that are really accountable
and who they can deal,
yes, the central government
will give them general authority
to operate in the country,
but they can deal directly
with the traditional leaders
who are best trusted by
the communities to deliver.
And so the model that I would suggest
is large international organizations
as to work with their local partners
to deal directly with the
traditional authorities.
The government is already getting,
although they always say it's not enough,
the government is already
getting a lot of money
from place like the World Bank,
the African Development Bank.
They use a sovereign capacity
to get funding for a lot of things.
But a lot of that funding
doesn't filter down to the communities.
The best way to get it to filter down
is to get a credible NGO
and require them to deal directly
with the traditional leaders
who will guide them a lot better.
And trust me, the communities
will benefit a lot more,
because those traditional leaders
are a lot more accountable
to their communities
than are national governments.
Of course, the national
governments still play a role
in the world coordination
of registration of NGOs.
But on a project-by-project basis,
the most efficient way
of impacting communities
is through their traditional leaders
and through NGOs and through
their traditional leaders.
- Okay, thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
I see Dr. Dahn has two fingers up.
So the floor is yours, Dr. Dahn?
- Yes, I just want to
complement what he said.
It is possible to support
local governments directly.
The same way I complained
about donor partners
falling on not being very transparent
is the same thing that
happens with the government,
and the central governments calling on
and not letting go to
the local governments.
Ideally, if you want that to happen,
the local government system,
the capacity need to be built.
The same systems you
have at the central level
needs to be in the local government office
and the different agencies
well built within their local.
Take for instance the
counties within the county,
which most of you will call
districts, and then they report,
so the local government office
who is headed by the superintendent.
When you look at Liberia,
you'll realize that some of the
services are decentralized to some extent.
But one institution
that will not decentralize
is Finance Ministry.
They tend to all own and
don't want to let go.
And it's difficult to understand why,
because the people who work
at the local government level
have went to the same schools you went to.
(voice muffling) People
graduated from the same schools
and you have the same degrees.
- Yes.
- It happens
in the health sector the same way.
In the health sector
you'll see one program
in immunization, for example.
The will forever be training of trainers.
They go to the local
level, they train trainers.
You expect that the people
they train are trainers
will scale down the training,
but the people at the central
will continue to go down
to the county and the district
to continue to do training.
So as a result, the trainers they train
can never have the opportunity to train,
but it takes the government
to make a serious
decision to decentralize.
It's easier to decentralize
with all the other ministries,
but they need to look
at the Finance Ministry
and see how they can
decentralize Finance Ministry
to support the local government,
and all the other things will follow.
That is very difficult
to do in our setting.
- All right, Paramount Chief Farley,
you had two fingers?
- Yeah, just to buttress.
I am a professional engineer
for over four decades.
So my bent is more to
see the world as it is
rather than to,
and say how will I get things done
based on how the world is.
As Dr. Dahn said, no Ministry of Finance
is going to decentralize.
No matter what the World
Bank or anybody else says.
I can give lots of examples.
I'm not even going to bother with that.
So the work around that
is work with these...
The donor partners can fund NGOs directly,
but let them be reputable NGOs
and let the donor partners get
feedback, monitoring systems,
that ensures that they have, in fact,
dealt with the traditional leaders
who are trusted by their communities.
I think that there's no way
government can stop that
as long as the the NGOs
are working in the country.
But to say that you're hoping,
because the World Bank has been
after our government forever
to decentralized, and they even have
a permanent decentralization secretariat
and nothing yet decentralized.
So instead of following that,
just go ahead and walk around it,
walk through these international NGOs,
get them to be credible
and walk directly with those leaders.
Nobody can stop that.
- Thank you, Paramount Chief Farley.
A next question from the audience says,
"Looking into future
outbreaks, what can technology,
"digital health, telemedicine,
"or connectivity be used
"to improve the handling of outbreaks?"
So, Dr. Thiam, I think
we can start with you.
(Sylla Thiam speaking French)
One question, so we have
only a five-minute warning.
"How should external actors,
"whether they be bilateral
or international NGOs,
"navigate the degrees
of tension or separation
"between traditional government
and central government?
"Typically there is for outsiders
"a need to go through central government
"in order to get to the
traditional government,
"which has both financial and
programmatic implications.
"So for those of us who
desire to work more closely
"with local communities
and traditional leaders,
"what advice would you
give for navigating this?"
So Paramount Chief Farley,
we'll start with you.
- You obviously need to register.
Once you're registered
as an NGO in the country,
your program itself, you can develop
over how you develop and
implement your programs,
but obviously you have to
register with some central agencies.
That's why it's a good workaround.
You're not required to
implement all of your programs
through the central government.
In fact, most NGOs
develop their own programs
and deal directly with local governments.
The problem is getting
the dependable NGOs,
because there's also a lot
of malfeasance within NGOs.
A lot of them spend a good
percent of their funds
just having meetings and
meetings and meetings on end,
which their own staff usually attends,
get a lot of per diems,
and most of that is
spent on that overhead,
rather than on actually
programmatic things
within the communities.
But I'm sure the best NGOs will find a way
of delivering most of the
funding to the program itself.
But I can assure you,
just to build on something,
Dr. Thiam had said,
right at independence,
there was a huge imbalance
between the level of
education and sophistication
between those in central government
and those in traditional institutions.
Not anymore.
Among paramount chiefs,
you have medical doctors,
you have lawyers.
I'm a professional engineer.
I'm a registered professional engineer.
I've also had done my masters
in public administration
and business administration,
and a lot of times we you actually have
a lot more capable resources
at the traditional governance level
than at the central government,
the government level.
So, working through those
NGOs, get the NGOs registered,
but don't hesitate to work directly
with the traditional leaders, because,
you know, we are getting
more and more sophisticated.
- All right, thank you,
Paramount Chief Farley.
And our last question will go to Dr. Dahn,
as we only have one minute left.
"What would you have done
differently to manage the crisis
"in terms of managing
resource mobilization,
"distribution channels to get
it to who needs it the most?
"And the problems of trust and credibility
"between citizens, NGOs,
and government players?"
So the last minute is yours, Dr. Dahn.
- Okay, for me, I will work in
building governance capacity.
I will work with them
in building the systems
that's supposed to be built for them
to be able to manage their own resources
plus donor resources.
An example is with the USAID funding
that is being managed by
the Ministry of Health,
the fixed amount reimbursement agreements.
This is an agreement between USAID
and the Ministry of Health.
(voice cutting out)
- Okay, well unfortunately
because of the connectivity,
and it is our final minute
here, we do have to end.
So I just want to say, you know,
thank you to our panelists
for a fantastic discussion,
and thank you all for joining us today.
We also wanna thank our sponsors,
the Yale Institute for Global
Health, the Walker Fund,
and the Council on African Studies
at the MacMillan Center at Yale.
The session was recorded
and will be posted
on the Institutes for Global Health's
Conversation Series playlist on YouTube.
We look forward to seeing
you at the next event
of the Global Health Conversation series.
Thank you all and take care.
- Thank you.
- And thank you for
providing the opportunity.
I hope it was helpful.
- It's been a pleasure.